okay welcome everybody we are looking at
uh
design review for machine learning for
upcoming version of orphan language
so where do we start
well i would just keep the first one
because it's probably the one that will
take more time so i don't know roger
what do you think is that the first one
it will take a lot of time or we put it
as a
which means i want to see a magenta
detector i've been excited about this
for a long time exactly exactly so yeah
i'm sure we're going to have to discuss
names and stuff so i i guess either we
skim through the rest or we just start
here maybe we just have another one it
just happened oh my gosh i think this
just the prototype build just crashed
when i opened docutools great actually i
had that happen
today too
or yesterday yeah
am i going to succeed here is it going
to fail completely
good point
but i'm a winner just crashed again
okay so it's
well um
i can open the documentation in the
earlier version and copy paste things
one
what just happened
wait a minute i was
oh for goodness sake okay hold on
those docker tools yeah i know but that
that was all right i'm so i need to pull
up the other
that's for the older version
and now for this version
i'll bring up your page here
and so i these are running in two
different versions
okay
image entity detect
oh
i think i pushed some fix to some typos
like an hour ago so if you if you pull
cds you should get the most recent
version
does it matter
well
not on the big scheme of things probably
but okay we're not going to save this
back so
okay
um
okay so let me understand what this is
really entity is that the right term
this is a thing to train
the mission of this thing is to train
you know
but it's sort of lightweight training
requires
relatively little you know not that many
examples because it it relies on
an already trained backbone
network
okay so i understand transfer learning
but so i don't understand
the function and we've been through this
before i mean that this should have
kind of you know the basic structure
should be
examples comma thing to look at
so in other words while you are
generating a classifier
with the one argument form there should
be a two argument form that just does
the whole job type thing
um
yeah the big
pro okay so you want to do like classify
that's what i think yes
i mean if you're going to have a name
like this
that's what we have to do
um i'm not super sure about that i'm
planning to make it faster but this
thing here it's an inherently slow
operation uh
i'm just wary of uh advertising that use
case if the training could take between
like thirteen okay that's fine exactly
what we had yesterday with i mean this
is what we have with with the noun form
versus the verb verb form
right
and um first point is i really don't
think we should call it entities
entities mean something very definite in
our system i think it's more like
objects
yeah i mean what we did the naming
scheme i think is great in the sense
it's uniform and it and it is entities
um but
but if you feel strongly about it no we
can't do that we've got all this entity
star functionality right what do you
think that the the detector function do
you think it's an end still an entity
detector function
because it's unified it goes out to you
know they both text entity detect and
image anti-detect producers okay we got
to get good names for these but but um
um
so originally we
we started by thinking of
generalizing just classify and actually
jerome convinced me that the the
trainers for text and images are not
i mean first we only have like two cases
that really make sense right now texts
and images and the trainers they have
very different
timings
and
they kind of the entry point are very
different so i like that we have a
single detector function at the end
uh i'm not so sure anymore that uh like
what i originally proposed month ago was
kind of a sub cases classify or object
classify component classifier i think we
were like toying with yes um
i'm not so sure we can actually provide
i mean that name would be kind of a very
why not i mean you're saying because it
only works for images and text
also i don't know i feel a bit
uncomfortable having a function that if
you put images will take three hours and
if you put text
will take like
less than a minute probably fine but
then we then let's not right now
have the master function that works
supposedly universally
i mean by the way ethan on our live
stream is commenting
about um
new entity objects yeah but this is the
these are new entities right this is
that's the whole point here i mean you
could argue that you could put entity
object there like stuff with head entity
instead of a string it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter i mean this is just a
payload i mean this is just like exactly
um
so
okay
let me understand what this is doing
i don't need to give the bounding box is
that a true statement
uh
no it's false like you we could make it
work that if you don't give it we
automatically infer that the bounding
box is the whole image i think i had the
design for that but in general like this
is like a toy example in general you
will have sub objects
not not the whole uh
if this is not classified let's say this
is right on the image
is there a way of encoding a region of
interest as part of the image object
not right now and definitely not for
text
so you're looking for a simpler simpler
training
sentence how do you get
don't we have a way of representing an
image with a region of interest for
other functions no i mean our goal is to
add annotations to images for that very
reason
um you know because there's not only
here but you can think of sort of
medical workflows that's kind of what
you do
um you mark up you know you mark up a
subpart and we should also imagine
annotations for text
we had a couple of meetings about that
the problem is that like string like
head string doesn't
it's like i know that's why so that's
why for example text element which is
what we use in text structure is the
kind of thing to go for i think
right text element allows you to
to structure up symbolically structure
what would otherwise just be a string
i look into that
and it seems very tailored to
grammatical units
more than well let's look at them we
should take it apart
because i think you know we have a
similar thing code element that we're
intending for abstract syntax trees for
code
i think it's going to be a family of
things okay but let me understand what's
going on here so this is saying
that in this image there's a single
object and
at that location it's this
so in the future we could expect that
the image would itself have been marked
up with annotations that could basically
say the same as that right-hand side
ideally yes
okay but at this point it could be even
annotation for both like you would have
bounding box and class
why should you provide the class
separately
no i i i agree i mean but i'm saying
that
even this picture
could have
one inbounding box for the main apple
one bounding box the leaf et cetera et
cetera et cetera yeah yeah
yes
and it's in its um okay
so in that case you could run the the
trainer on a list of images with such
annotation scheme and that would be it
all right
question in
um image
contents
yep
what does that return relative to
the um
if i just run here if i run image
contents on this
does it return something in the same
format as that thing is eating
uh animals no it's returning an
association is returning something
similar to the output
let's take a look here
so what i'm going to say is clearly
this
um
this right hand side should be able to
be the thing that you get back from
image contents
yes definitely definitely and and
i i'm supporting like i haven't exposed
to the top level uh
everything but the internal design is
supporting actually its own output
so you can you can refeed that
[Music]
so this concept of a concept is probably
not the right thing here
i mean that's the um well that's the
concept entity that's always the concept
entity i know that but i mean so i'm i'm
thinking
that there should be a an element here
that's called identification or some
other
some other thing that is in general the
this thing here
right
needs a name where it to be in an
association
is typically class
we have been using class i mean this is
exactly the same class as classify so
okay fine
and does it have an association form
that uses class also yeah i mean if you
look at this is an old page so the
output here you see the
try detector on the new image in the in
the rough page it says class app per
probability region
we actually rename region to bounding
box because we we were attempting to
have a more consistent syntax using
region everywhere but it was actually
very confusing because we use bounding
box for images all the time it's about
roblox it's not a region
or something it could be the shape of a
you know it could be shape of a potato
you know some
that could be a region in our in our
computational geometry system yeah yeah
i mean it was it was an
uh aborted attempt to have the same
key for text and images but in in the
end we just went for bounding box for
four images and uh yeah class is going
to be apple we we i debated this with
rom a bit and his uh what is in the
updated page his proposal was to have
the um class and image
as as return properties so you what you
see here is image and concept in uh in
image contents
so that you immediately immediately see
what's there
and what it is and for text you would
have string an image
but i mean
yeah sorry sorry my bad stringing
so image means the carved out piece of
the image in its bounding box yeah we
use it also for stuff like find faces
you can ask for bounding box or image
all right so we have some consistency
there let's go back here
yep um
okay
so what you're doing
is you are spending a long time
building
um
the
uh um
um you know building this object
whatever you're calling it here the
entity detector function i don't like
the name
but um
um
and you say the workflow
is such that it is implausible ever
to give
here are the things i'm looking for this
is what i'm looking in and to have that
work in in real time so to speak that
you're always going to end up doing the
one argument for i think for images at
least it's not realistic i have a design
in mind i mean an implementation in mind
but it's not not mature yet the the main
problem here is that
the text is very easy to piece into to
cut into pieces you have like the
boundaries of words is a very clear
thing yeah so what what jerome is doing
is like he he did he handled that the
text part that's pure fine-tuning of the
of the classification but for images you
need to re-learn to find these new
objects and that is what takes a lot of
time
why is it all this yolo technology why
isn't that relevant to this
it is i mean the point is that you don't
have any guarantee that what the network
was trained before
is uh
is relevant for your new classes so if i
want to find an object the network if
you can if you use a proposal for from
the old detector
if you miss
the new object in this proposal's list
then you will never find anything
okay but to me this sounds like a
technical issue which is going to get
solved maybe not this year
no
yeah exactly
i'm already experimenting with a kind of
class agnostic object proposals it's
just not my tool yet
ethan our live stream suggests that
detect should be the super function
that's an interesting suggestion
well we're planning so here i
added this image until that name
because i was trying to i was trying and
you have some examples below in the if
you scroll down in the page i was trying
to see if this could hold
other detectors you know like find faces
or or find text
they they are sub
examples of this and we could have
similar to what we have like built-in
classifiers
this could be very easily extensible you
we could have detectors as
well from functional positive
submissions i think roger proposes a
nice idea about extensibility and we can
pre-train a bundle of those
so this is this could be an umbrella
thing where are the classifiers where
are our named classifiers they're not in
all that repository no they are
pocketlets they're they're apocalypse
they became so i mean one thing we
should be doing is making a repository
of those right the named classifiers
that's actually something we should have
already done i mean like there are
things in the neural net repository like
there's a demo that i often use
of um that that neat network that you
give a photograph it tells you where in
the world that was taken
yeah
right
yeah that should be a built-in
classifier
uh we look into that a bit like how to
migrate because
that thing came way before the the data
repositories in general and uh
i think it just stayed there for a while
because at first we didn't have
versioning you know it was a bunch of
technical limitations but i was
discussing this actually before leaving
uh with with timothy and probably for
the next version when we have a bit of
time we we were looking at um
how to migrate
all those um
okay but let me be specific i mean what
we have right now is a neural net
repository one of the things we're
planning
is more lightweight repository making
and so what
what is coming out of this discussion is
we should have a classifier repository
we should have an anomaly detector
repository we should have a detector
repository etc okay that would be my
next question like do we want to
proliferate repositories or
start like subsection inside one
repository okay and then usually
repositories because that's what you
know it's intended to be a general
framework the repository you know the
resource system is a general framework
and every repository so now we need a
repository repository we do yes we do
there's already a plan for that
and um
okay now this this answer my my my
concern because i was a bit wary of the
cost of uh setting up another one of
those
the idea is that they're gonna be
lightweight i mean like for example one
roger that you should have heard about
is the is the color palettes repository
which i think we really need i mean i
want to get rid of these random sort of
things where we've got you know a random
set of palettes here these should be
repositories
the the color data i think yeah yes
should be a repository
and um because you know there's a lot of
things we don't have there and each one
should have its page it should have a
name
blah blah blah it should be searchable
for you should be able to have guide
pages for it you know the whole nine
yards which is something that comes with
the repositories but doesn't come with
something that's just a little palette
somewhere
okay can we can we avoid using new heads
like uh and this is i ask this also to
bring back the discussion because it's
relevant to this detection framework so
can they classify the built-in
classifiers in the repository be
accessed through the classified head
i don't see any reason why i shouldn't
be just like net model accesses things
in the neural net repository exactly but
yeah but the net model is not me it
evaluates to a neural network it's kind
of a
it was a thing added on the side like a
kind of a nice wrapper like classify we
already have as ahead but i i mean i
agree
my point is i don't think that there's
any you know if i say classify
like
um
it comes out as a classifier function
right
yeah exactly which is just fine i mean
this is just it will retrieve its
classifier function
from
the um
uh you know from the repository
that's just fine
beautiful
this is the right way to do it
now the question is whether we can do
that with detect
okay and so
what would happen if we had okay so this
would be an image detect
and and then it would be
and the thing is okay so you're
detecting things in the image
now how does that go with i mean the
other detect functions that we have we
have anomaly detect right
and
yeah
color detect oh yeah and then we have
oh that's uh to find um
something close to that color in in the
image so you see okay so what does it
look like what kind of a thing does it
mean a mask
mask
okay
that's similar to the like crossing
detect
edge detect
okay which return masks
exactly
which was our kind of standard things
like other list of points or or a mask
where our two typical return types for
images when you were looking for things
um
right ethan is commenting
these classifiers need to be benchmarked
and they need
test data sets
and performance data yeah
suggestion
in the neural net repository for example
it's a good suggestion i mean i'm sure
we could automatically add a bunch of
that stuff given a test the trade a test
training set we could absolutely add
performance information although i don't
know quite how we would do it because
it's like performance on what i mean on
my on my desktop computer or my
you know on a is there as good
standardizing no you you don't typically
for performance you don't typically mean
speed
they mean
you know what a range of problems that
can be solved that's usually what we
call skulls
but they call everything precision of
recall and things like that
yes yes exactly accuracy
stuff like that but you can also report
the flop so in that case
no okay it's a very heavy system or like
four tpus uh this is the the flops
we do report performance when we have
them in the net repository i'm actually
pushing for a bit more more tables of
them look i think that we should call
this object detect i think detect on its
own is too
uh you know there's too many of these
things and i think what we would then we
have is image object detect
which would be
this function here
which is essentially what you're talking
about except we're calling it object
detect
so we create these two with the idea
that when we are ready we create a
general object attack that can take
everything that's that would be what i
would think yes
and i mean i would say that um
um
is object attack gonna fit correctly
with text do you think
i was thinking about that
because
that was the dilemma we had when we were
trying you know thinking of names yeah
well what are we calling i mean in text
cases what how do we describe text cases
because text cases can can
you know detect all kinds of weird
things
yeah that's the pre-trained version of
this i know being of type whatever it is
right
um
let me see
it's not even text entities it's not
entities because you can do things like
you know it doesn't matter whether it's
an entity we can have things like nouns
and so on
yeah
what do you call all that then content
types is what we're calling it
um
look whatever happened to our idea
of having kind of image patterns
as the thing that would represent
you know in classify
okay i'm confused but back ages ago like
three years ago or something we had a
design for these kinds of things that
involved some kind of image pattern
construct we we thought about that
it's um
it it isn't giving
like if you wanted to evaluate
isn't giving it like you you will still
have to find features in a meaningful
way which is uh i mean the big problem
is
you need you need the full image to do
to do the training so if i accept only
the feature
i can only do that
with the other approach that i would
like to do in the future where you have
something that is able to detect
object proposal everywhere like
semantically segment an image and then
you use your your pattern object to to
match and find if something is closed or
not
but right now you need to train the the
localization part and for that is very
difficult to say before what are the
features that you need you you want to
start from the full image
i see so we throw away too much
information that i i would i would like
that as well but yeah if we if we could
segment properly in
in a meaningful way then that image
partner object would basically yeah
would be a good vector representation of
the image
why
am i not seeing feature oh it's feature
extract not feature detect
um
okay so
image
look i mean one possibility
i don't know i don't really like that
very much text content detect
image content detect
the problem with detect is that
these things are returning
a mask indicating where the detection
occurred
yes all of them they're not returning
what was they're not returning the cases
analog of that
they're returning the position version
not the cases version
well we do have um
for all the anomaly detection feature
extraction
missing imputation we had this this
three-fold thing where you you have
like for example we have feature extract
feature extraction
and feature extraction function
and one of the two returns the function
and the other one
operates on the data no i know but
that's i'm making a different point here
i'm saying
there are two things when you try and
find an apple in an image there are two
things you want the specific apple you
found
and you want
as opposed to you know because you're
feeding in a class of things the class
of apples but you want the specific
apple
and you want its bounding box
right just like
just like facial features whatever
no sorry i'm not sure
no
i think you want where and what is what
you're saying right yes that's correct
okay but these ones here the what is
given like edge it is an edge max is
but these more general watts you know
where there's a whole world in the what
we want the specific what
we're more specific what no i know i
know i know you you're returning the
cases of
i mean
let me see
it's just like a classifier you don't do
that because you're given the whole
thing and you're just saying how is it
classified
exactly
okay so what we need here
[Music]
um
ah let me think
so i mean i think i understand the
functionality and i mean in the text
example i assume
what i'm doing is i'm i'm saying what
what what are you giving us as training
data there you say this word
we give a text which is a string which
is a position which is similar to the
image and then he said this position is
furniture this position is okay this one
is trying only on furniture but the one
below is fruit or sport for example
so it's like a position in class similar
to image
nathan is complaining there's no
multi-modal multi-net encoder examples
no captioning summarization what's vqa i
don't know what the qa is
i think that's what we're dealing with
here is is this question of what happens
how do you get something where there is
both
a this is an elephant and
here's an elephant here's a rhinoceros
and here's you know
okay so we're both feeding in
um
oh it's kind of weird yeah okay so
you're going to fix that you're going to
actually give the string here right
you're not just going to give the
position
yeah yeah the then we change yeah we
changed if you if you pull cvs you will
already see that we we have string and
position and in the in the image case we
have image and
bounding box
right
i'm not sure what the net functionality
i mean that the things like captioning
is on don't we have networks that do
that we just don't have we have not made
a standardized version
no i don't think we have converted any
captioning we definitely haven't trained
any captioning network
right i mean but it's easy to take this
output to highlight i mean actually this
should make sure that this fits together
with highlight image right for
yes i have an example uh
if you if you go to the image and detect
life and we would like something similar
to highlight image for highlight text we
would
i thought we had a highlight text do we
never did we finished that design or not
i don't know who works on
text is one of these where we don't
um
it's a little bit distributed right it's
not i thought it was jerome dealing with
those kinds of things well jerome jerome
did a lot of work for the text
cases if you go to text cases you will
see the highlight snippet
but not sort of the core infrastructure
stuff no no i mean he did that on its
own because only on his own because he
needed he needed the functionality but
yeah there was a discussion
that at that time i wasn't part of so i
didn't know where i don't know what it
went about doing that generically like a
general framework like highlighted for
for for text
right but something we should talk about
further okay coming back to this
so
the issue is the name of the function
that is going to
take
uh
it's going to take specifications of sub
pieces
and it is going to so the return value
will be like facial features will be
this whole association correct
um
well we were thinking about the whole
association we wanted to add more
properties so we are not returning all
of them we will have
ideally a default set of properties that
we return and then you can specify
if you want something different you can
specify that you can say just give me
the image or
give me also the probability give me the
highlight and snippet
right but i'm not buying the fact that
you're never going to be able to do a
one-shot version of this
and by the way you could even do some
behind-the-scenes caching to help with
that and so on
yeah i mean we can have the design we we
we we can support it it is not not
killing anybody it is
but this is also something that was
bothering me a bit in all those
classifications or like not
[Music]
not
not detect uh functions in machine
learning that uh
i almost never want the the direct
result because i want to tweak this
stuff and experiment and uh
i'm always wary of throwing away even 10
minutes
if i cannot reuse it
right okay fine
okay but yeah but we can definitely
support it it's it's not not a blocker
right so look the natural name
i wonder about content detect
content is fine for text let's say
audio is image content yeah we have
image content
it's
oh we have image contents don't we it's
the same as text content one is the one
that
tries to find everything and gives you a
data set as a result and the cases
function is like cases you you put you
put what you want well i would argue
then that we should just standardize on
uh image content detect because content
is i agree with this is okay okay this
was good this is kind of what we were
looking for to to standardize on but but
right you know the content like it's
better yeah okay
all right okay because then we can have
a content detector function exactly
so then this becomes
yeah content detector function
and eventually it would just be pure
content detect not text content or image
content detect yeah
should we do that immediately and just
say it only supports text and images
right now
we can we started the design that way
jerome actually lobbied me very
very hard to to separate them and at a
certain point he was able to convince me
i don't remember why he was able to
convince me but
he was definitely able to convince me i
think was
they have almost the same options
yeah we we tried very hard not to
uh depart i mean we thought that
them together so the
and i tried to keep them together so
by the way i mean the image content
detect of face
is going to give a content detector
function basically of face
exactly yeah yeah
so it's kind of just the pass-through
thing that doesn't matter you could say
image content detector of that too
um sorry
no i mean look you say image content
detect of face
returns an image content detector
that is basically a face image content
detector
yeah it would return like a content
detector function of typeface like
pretty pretty i know i know i know but
as well you could have typed in content
detector function of quotes face and
that would have been an equivalent yeah
yeah i was actually thinking of doing
that
if you want to have that as an entry
point i'm not sure if you want this
image and text as entry point we could
have that you can access the
the the reason why i didn't implement
this is this classifier is doing
differently but even for classify i
would even prefer classifier function to
take the
let's let's look at that and as we put
it into a repository
we can you know
clean that up
okay so
what i'm seeing here
makes me think you should do one more
parcel can we just make content detect
a
you know the single function from the
beginning
if we can't we'll have to have these two
as experimental functions and then
subsequently i think
um julia can we just
just first of all transfer these names
to be sort of the content case and then
we write a third page which is the
overall thing yeah and then to see what
happens yeah
sure okay all right let's move on
um i mean unless there's more to talk
about with these functions doesn't look
like there is
no no i mean this piece wasn't the main
the the name thing and the
kind of how to fit them in was was the
main uh okay fine let's move on the main
point
okay dimension reduction so that means
feature space plot starts to look
different uh i mean we are not using t
is me
we i think for feature space probably
something faster but this will be this
is a very popular method and we want one
so it's just an alternative method so
it's method arrow umap or something is
an alternative method which will work in
feature space plus exactly exactly okay
okay
we are working now to make it as fast as
possible should be a fast method so we
we are writing some custom code to make
it faster in implementation
okay predictor function classifier
function decision tree
as a tree expression that's cool i want
to see that
okay so here we have a design problem
because
this is something that i really want to
have
but we need to decide so right now i
think it makes sense
only as a toy thing i don't even know if
you want to expose it because and there
is
the reason why is
uh we had three methods like decision
tree random forest and the gradient
boosted the train trees
the point is that we have very
sophisticated
uh data processing pipeline like
standardization
missing imputation
conversion to numerical vectors and the
three is trained on the output of that
so
as much as i like to
probe this direction because i really
want to have the stuff in three form um
[Music]
it's it will not be immediately used
useful because you will not see the
input of a tree the the the nodes you
split on is not the original data
so okay how different is it i mean the
standardization and things like that you
can kind of work through okay but if
this is a string for example it might
become something you know a vector of
length four
what those things represent it's just an
embedding so you mean after the after
the feature detection you're saying the
tree obviously no no
detection
encoders i mean yeah i think it's the
same thing like it's a the feature of
feature structure that's right right
right
yes it operates after the encoder yeah
what you're saying so we were exploring
with jesse like one idea was
if you want to work to to go down this
um
interpretable machine learning way we
could
have for some setting that we always
train a tree
to represent whatever like black box
classifier i'm between a tree okay so
you've got a mapping
going through the encoder you you have
an elephant and the elephant turns into
a vector of numbers yes
yeah right
and
so now
and then
okay so so just okay
given a particular data set
you know
these elephants these
rhinoceroses turned into these sets of
numbers then you know
there is a break between two sets of
numbers
that is the decision tree yes
so a way you could visualize that is
you know
you know there is a break in this in the
in sort of uh feature space so to speak
for the decision tree but just like a
feature space plot
you're basically visualizing
you know the i mean like how are you
going to represent you've got
rhinoceroses and elephants on one side
and you've got uh you know cats and
ferrets on the other side or something
right
and and they are split in the decision
tree
okay
how would you ever imagine you're going
to sew elephants and rhinoceroses other
than the way we do it in feature space
plot which is to take the original data
and show the the elephants and
rhinoceroses
so in other words what i'm claiming is
your decision tree
should have
you know there is some slice some point
at which it makes the decision that
somewhere in between elephants and
rhinoceroses and cats and ferrets
okay
okay i understand what you say i'll stop
you here because the point is a feature
vector
like um classify is more generic than
that the future vector could be
one text element a sentence a number a
color and a date okay and everything is
dimensional reduced together so i know
i know i'm just saying there is a set
okay so here's my point
let's say there's a hundred initial
i mean
the training data contains some amount
of data right
and in principle
you could represent decision space so
what is this what is a single
break in the in the decision tree it's
basically in a feature space it is a
line in feature space
right it's a slice and feature space has
all of these different animals laid out
in a feature space right
and the a particular branch in the in
the decision tree
is these number these animals go to the
left these animals go to the right
the i think the real point is that i'm
not sure i should check but i'm all like
99 sure that not all the feature
extractors are invertible and this is
what i'm not saying it's invertible i'm
not saying it's invertible
it doesn't have to be invertible all
that has to be true
is that
the
okay here's what i'm suggesting so if i
go to um
uh
why i have been doing so much live
streaming today that i have not eaten
enough i am going to fail through lack
of food soon
especially since we have another live
stream coming right up
um
okay so let's take one of these cats and
dogs okay
so what i'm saying is you've got certain
training data
okay and you could lay it out in a
feature space if you wanted to
so i'm saying the decision tree you can
always draw that with respect to your
original data as some kind of
partitioning of this original data
every tree branch is some partitioning
of data correct
is partitioning the feature space
yes yes
i understand but you can represent that
as a partitioning of the original data
you've drawn a feature space plot
and so which is a horribly dimensional
reduced version of feature space
but
the that what i'm saying is you know
there is some separator might be not be
a straight line there's no guarantee of
that there's some separator these guys
goes on one side and these guys go on
the other side
right no i i see your point i'm not sure
that mathematically it it will be it
will be always possible um
i i i want to look into that more
how could it fail to me i don't
understand that it can always you can
always make you know
with respect to the original data no it
always is it's always a partition yeah
but every every cut must be a partition
of this original data goes this side
this original data goes that side
and so whatever you need to describe
that analytically no you don't that's
not what i'm saying i you don't need to
that's my whole point my whole point is
imagine the tree okay you're drawing a
decision tree what i'm saying is all you
do
in the nodes of the decision tree all
you do
is you give the actual
you know the 300
examples of training data that go to the
left
the 400 examples that go to the right
okay so in other words uh okay no no
sorry uh okay
this was my confusion i was
uh so okay to do this you need to
basically save the whole training data
together with a classifier i was
actually under the assumption that you
only have the classifier function not
the original training set
but
yes if you have the original training
set you can do that
right
so then the decision tree
what you would do as a visualization of
the decision tree
is you would say okay i'm going to make
samples of these different things
sliding on one side or the other
yeah in that case you can in yeah yeah
that's as a way
to make a decision tree
um
but that's more like something
i i think that some of these have kind
of these different uh different homes
depending on
and and properties depending if the
property is in classifier measurement or
in information because if you didn't
classify measurement you have some data
and then we could do that in the case
yes right but what would what did you
imagine decision tree would put out i
mean i was thinking of it as an actual
decision tree meaning that
there's a boolean condition at the node
right but the point is that the
condition is on
for i mean this thing is
it requires that encoder to run but it
would be on the encoded data yes right
so there are two decision trees that are
relevant either on the encoded data
because you have mapped by the feature
space by the encoder you've mapped it
into you put in space effectively yeah
and so at that point it is an algebraic
condition
or linear condition often you know it's
it's a
it's a condition in euclidean space or
for a nominal three for nominal split is
uh is it uh one two and three goes in
this direction four and five go in the
other direction
fine
well so
a
this is more like that this is saying of
the thousand training examples
400 go in this direction 600 go in that
direction
it's think about it like a nominal
splitter yeah categorical splitter right
and that's an alternative
the other case that you talked about
once you've euclidianized it so to speak
once you've
uh sort of specified it
um
then
it's something uh
um
what am i trying to say that then then
then you can be more algebraic about
those conditions but either of those is
perfectly interesting
either case is interesting but what
would you imagine that we produce in
that that first case um with the
examples
like which first case sorry that
when you haven't encoded it and sort of
did you expect the decision to have a
bunch of examples sitting at the various
nodes yes that's what i would expect oh
i would expect that the yes that's what
i would expect okay and
in principle it could have the whole bag
of all training data that went to the
left and all training data that went to
the right
i mean essentially pointers to all those
pieces of training data
and and you could sample it with
examples of that training data
i think that will be an interesting
decision tree i think it'll be a useful
decision tree i think i could imagine
something where you know you can drill
down well which exact you know
what were the features so to me this is
somewhat i can see if i can learn
something from that actually
right i mean in a sense learn
distribution
is
um
uh
you know
learn distribution is the thing that is
sort of taking these images for example
and turning them into a space-like thing
um
things like feature space plots don't
deal with hundreds of thousands of
examples and they should
why don't they
what
there are two bottlenecks here like one
is
and i expect is the the
not so big one visualization and the
probably the biggest one is feature
extraction that it might take a lot of
time a lot of time to process do we
parallelize the feature extraction
well if it is a neural network which
typically is it is already paralyzed
because no but it's not it's only it's
only within it's only multi-threaded
it's not
you know for example we don't have
what happens if you have a hundred cores
can you actually run if if it's feature
detecting zillions of things you should
be able to run that in parallel
but it is i i mean so the neural network
is you know if you have let's say you
have a 64 core machine no i i'm i'm i'm
not talking about that i'm talking about
if we have our parallel framework like i
have 157 cores i think
yeah but then so none of that is
probably no none of that's used no this
is not it doesn't support parallelized
but
i think that most of the federal staff
are neural networks so the cooling
powered lines wouldn't give any
improvement yes it would if you have
multiple machines it would or multiple
machines right
right is paralyzed working on okay i
didn't even know if it was woodworking
machines okay of course it does that's
its main point
yeah it's his main point it's not just
single it's it's whatever kernels you
have available
right
i mean i think that look by the way the
business about the visualization of
feature space plot that needs to be
looked at
because i've noticed that issue as well
that you know we just need to make sure
that it actually works with very large
numbers of
you know points and so on
okay i think that that okay so that can
probably be parallelized that's the the
actual feature extraction but the other
key point when you visualize big things
is that you don't visualize everything
you sub-sample no i i know i know we
need drill down but the first thing is
there's just straight
optimization of the way feature space
plot works we've done a couple of
iterations of it if somebody who's
taking notes here we need to point that
out to brett and make sure that we do
one more round of that
true fair
i've got it
okay
um
let's it's probably going to come back
to the ml team
right
uh
see marco is suggesting
for image content detect you can have an
operator form
that finds the
bounding box it's more complicated
because you can both find the
the thing that was detected
as well as
the
um
yeah
um we need to go to our next
meeting which is also a live stream well
i'm gonna ask for another
of this yes please yes we need to do
that ethan is is commenting that we
should have
a documentation section of real world
examples with at least a hundred
thousand
samples and it's a perfectly reasonable
suggestion i mean in feeder space blog
though i mean no in general in machine
learning
yeah
that's i typically keep it low because
uh
there was complaint about the size of a
rough page now that we ship it
separately no but this is where we use
data repository and other things to pull
in big
and i think the main point is just to
show the workflows
and perhaps they should be in workflow
documentation to show the workflows for
large-scale computations so to speak
because there are different issues that
come up like this thing about feature
you know like the feature detection
being parallelizable which i hadn't even
thought of but that's a reason i i think
you know what i did a bunch of feature
space stuff for the physics project
about a year ago and i did do a bunch of
parallelization there i did all kinds of
weird hacks like for example one weird
hack i was doing was um uh on parallel
machines i was rasterizing a bunch of
things
to use
as as the images to display and so on
you know i had to do a bunch of weird
hacks
particularly involving parallelization
to get that stuff through
we can definitely look into improving
that i think it's probably due time to
to have an update and about this thing
like one stuff that is not documented
here but it's supported uh is you can
use it the
image content detector
with files like it trains out of core as
well if you want oh that's interesting
we can probably should be documented um
yeah i mean i i i preferred that is uh
again this started with classifier was
another point of difference uh i think i
didn't do that at the beginning because
it was between
is not super clear if you have a single
head should you expect an image head an
image a file with an image or a file
with something else
but
i want to look in and if you want to
bring back the unified design i can look
into that again i think it'll be good
because that is the only way to train
with a very very big device we should we
should wrap for this meeting and for
those following the live stream we have
one coming up about graphs geometry and
graphics
the 3g
yes actually sounds very uh
very out of date it should be 5g at
least or 6g or something by now right
okay i will uh see you guys in a moment
uh we'll be on